today live from the st louis chess club
we have a repeat of a classic match-up
in the u.s women's chess championship
defending champion irina crush once
again faces anna zatonski and like so
many times before it promises to be
thrilling look at their classic finish
from the 2008 championship
that happens right now at the 2014 u.s
test championships here in st louis
hello and welcome to the 2014 u.s chess
championships and u.s women's here in st
louis the capital of chess in america
we are in the beautiful central west end
right across the street from the world
chess hall of fame at the saint was
chess club which gary kasparov calls the
nicest test club in the world
this is the sixth year running that the
us chess championship and the u.s
women's have been held here and as we
see the players are beginning their
games
we've got a lot of excitement today um i
can't wait to see how the games unfold
we're really at the critical moment here
both championships
we see baruch and kobien and sam
shanklin already beginning their game
i'm jennifer shahadi this is grandmaster
yasser sarawan pleasure to be with you
today jen i'm excited as well and let's
take a look at the standing in the u.s
chess championship
we have a verusion of kobien
he grew up in armenia moved to los
angeles now he's basically a local
speaker kansas
that's right and he is a point ahead of
the field here in the us chess
championship outstanding performance and
right behind him within striking
distance a one point deficit godda
kamsky our defending champion and
alexander lenderman who's had a really
topsy-turvy event
over in the women's championship ana
zatonski's dominating so far
she is a point ahead of her nearest
rival of course none other than
grandmaster irina crush
and luckily for irina they play today so
she has a chance to catch up with anna
with a win in his game
meanwhile tata avrahamian is also within
striking distance
let's see what grandmaster maurice
ashley has to say about the critical
match-ups today at the women's and u.s
championship
it's no doubt that today is a big day
for both championships first of all the
men battle
it's all about varus and okobian he's
playing against grandmaster sam shanklin
who is known to be an opening specialist
particularly with the white pieces so he
will be testing var in this round and
perusian definitely has a challenge now
because he is being chased after this
game by two amazing contenders first of
all godakomski the defending champion
who is looking to hunt him down and
catch him if possible they will be
playing tomorrow and he will then have
to play against linderman who's also
only a point behind lindeman was an
early leader in the championships
looking to get that league back so varus
and necobian will want to do very well
today in order to be ready for those two
games however it's all about the women
this time it's irina and anna yet again
and the magic number is eight they're in
round eight of the championships in the
last eight games they have played
actually in the eight games they have
played in the championships they are
tied two two and four draws and also in
the last eight championships guess
who've won these two women as well and
they have split those eight four to four
well irina has the edge there actually
because in 1998 she won her first title
so she's sitting on five titles right
now anna zatunsky does not want to lose
today she definitely wants to press and
if she can manage to win this game then
she will assure herself of the fish
championship but no doubt the defending
champion arena crush has a lot to say
about that so expect an exciting battle
today back to you guys
that's right and remember our arena
crash when she won her first
championship she was only 14 years old
can you believe that
it's stunning it really really is
stunning
last year when she played against she
was actually black and she won on the
black side of the king's indian defense
right i recall that game very vividly as
black
built up this wonderful attack on the
king side in the king's indiana
in king's indian defense and it was a
very very nice game by arena but today
is an epic battle between these two
great rivalry spanning the years and
really this is the deciding game uh for
the championship still crazy things can
happen in round nine but i expect the
outcome of this game to determine the
winner although if irena wins then
they're actually only
then we could have a playoffs
we would have a high chance for a
playoff but obviously the ninth round
will also determine whether both players
earn that right clear and uh in this
game it looks like irena has decided to
play without the d4 mode she's played c4
and g3 you know ana zataski's most
famous win against irena crash was back
in the 2009 u.s women's chess
championship where she had
a very quick win with the black pieces
and she ended up snagging irina's queen
on the queen side it was this really
nice little track
and that was in a queen's gambit decline
so this kind of
stops that that's true and with the move
g2 g3 essentially what i think arena is
trying to say with this move g2 g3 is
we're going to have a very long battle
it won't be determined by the opening uh
white just is going to set up a fortress
type of position on the
uh king side uh have a very flexible
approach to the center and the queen
side and to postpone the battle uh
far down the road so to speak well i
have mixed feelings about that though
because i've always felt irene has been
um better prepared than honestly in the
opening stage yesterday of course it was
an exception exactly but but that's a
little different because anna knew
exactly what alyssa was gonna play right
so she had that specific opening to
prepare in the rest day but in general
it seems like anna's openings are a
little bit less dangerous and like tatev
abrahamian said when she was down here
she feels that ana's great strength is
just like kind of you know keeping the
tension and you know kind of inducing
people to make mistakes well she's such
a great uh experienced player and such a
strong master player herself that uh
it's not easy to out player and it's
nice the idea it's nice that ana's a
little rusty and maybe not the most
up-to-date in her opening
theoretical battles but she's known for
playing these very very solid defenses
just great preparation can't overcome
great defense and oftentimes you see in
these championships that good defense
wins
the other reason i don't love this
opening decision by crush is that
because she hasn't
uh played a line where she can spit out
the first 10 to 20 moves i think we're
almost
so likely i was gonna say almost
guaranteed but i didn't want to over
deliver over promise but we are so
likely today to see another time
scramble i mean even in the openings in
the last three games where
irena has had
a lot of preparation she's gotten the
time pressure three games in a row
exactly so the beginning of the
tournament a lot steadier but
uh i mean in in this game where they're
out of theory on on probably move six or
seven what do you think the chances are
for a time scramble
it gets high it just depends um on the
type of battle that is going to occur in
the next five ten moves if it's going to
be an open battle you could see a lot of
things get traded and then simplified or
if it's it's a slow
battle where people are building up then
the possibility of time trouble really
starts to loom because both players have
been favoring the use of their clock
especially arena crush who has gotten
down to seconds before making her moves
one second one time and two seconds
another dad which is shocking right
exactly so
um i'm sure obviously irina has a great
coach and i'm sure they have their
reasons but on the surface
i'm not excited about this although it
looks like anna is the one who's um
not that i'm not excited we're gonna
have a great battle but i'm not a fan of
the decision okay well in this exact
moment what is anna spending so much of
her time about she could just play
bishop e7 here go into uh pardon me
bishop g2 has been played bishop e7 here
go into a closed catalan or an open
catalan but
um irina's move order has given ana the
opportunity to capture early
oops sorry excuse me bishop g2 has been
to capture early on c4 since this pawn
is not yet on the d4 square oftentimes
we see this variation queen a4 check
knight d7 queen takes or let's say
castles a6
queen takes c4
d5 and c5 and because the pawn is
already on c5 before white's pawn is on
d4 we often see this type of line
d3 and black has been known to get
pretty even play out of this specific
variation so what ana is debating is
should i allow a catalan which gives
white a small plus or should i go for
this type of position i don't even know
what the name for this
type of position might might be
which um
denies uh a white her small but clear
persistent edge that she might get in
the catalan so actually a rather big
decision and early in the game and on is
taking a lot of her time um
to get familiar with the type of battle
that's coming ahead up ahead i mean to
be fair anna's also had some time
pressure in this tournament but it seems
like it's not has been so bad when she
gets into the 30-second increment it
seems like her positions are a little
bit less critical right he's getting
into the 40th move with these massively
critical positions where she needs the
time whereas anna like might have been
down to 36 increments yesterday but she
was up to pawns right in a simplified
position and her and
and the game doesn't hang in the balance
and in arena's case
when she's gotten down so low on the
clock literally the
move is critical and part of that is bad
luck and also some good luck because
sometimes her opponent had uh actually
twice her opponent had winning moves in
a round move 39 right so on one hand was
bad luck because she had she blundered
around that time on the other hand it
was good luck that it wasn't one move
later right it's true well our defending
champion has played well enough in the
tournament to have uh to put herself in
second position second place and in the
position where she were to win today she
gets a tie for first going into last
round but in truth irina's play after
round three hasn't been as dominating as
uh her play and women's championships
have last year was very good really
impressed
and like you know trying out new
openings yeah it was a extremely
impressive performance whereas this
year's not quite as the dominating
performance but that could also make for
some excitement for us absolutely and we
have uh
another principal battle in the us chess
championship with jacqueline white
against
ocobian now what a lot of people are
going to be rooting for sam shanklin in
this game sure because it could it would
uh bring var back into the pack so to
speak you could rip up the standings
completely if shanklin were to win this
game exactly although shanklin himself
not in contention anymore
right but there is an undercurrent to
the battle for the u.s championships um
essentially the u.s olympiad team is a
five-person squad
four players are fairly much assured sam
shanklin is in a contest with ray robson
lenderman and others for that fifth
place so kind of on the bubble precisely
they're precisely they're precisely on
the bubble so sam
wants a good result out of this
championships as does rey as does alex
slenderman
to give themselves a boost to get into
the olympiad
um daniel noradiski is still a little
his ratings aren't as high as
to get him into the bubble so but he
could just win three games and win the
championship
that would get him into the u.s olympiad
that would get him on the u.s olympiad
team for sure and if that gives him a
playoff there's a chance of it uh kobe
would have to lose his game so we always
talk in this tournament about a copian's
big choice between the french and the
cairo khan this game he did favor
and we have this principled advance
variation let's take a quick look at the
game so sam opened up with the most
aggressive e2 e4 you need to know a lot
of theory to handle this opening move
well
c7 c6
the karo khan
black jockeys for control of the center
as well brings his pawn to d5 attacking
white's pawn on e4 lots of choices by
white but the considered the most
aggressive choice is the advanced
variation of the conor con exactly what
sam played i'm pretty sure var had
expected that
um advanced variation bishop f5 now why
is the advanced variation so much more
popular in the carroll con well it is
more popular in the carroll than it is
in the french by far yes why is that um
the the principal reason
is that in the um
in the french
in the karakan defense this bishop on
on c8
oftentimes for example in the main line
can develop itself rather early as we're
seeing here
in the french defense
e4 oops i beg your pardon e4 this is the
french defense e7 e6 d4 d5
the bishop on c8
has a hard time finding an effective
square
in the
advance
variation of the french after the move
e5 there are many variations where the
b7 b6 followed by bishop a6 black can
easily trade off his light squared
bishop now you're saying that actually
the bishop is better in the french than
the cara con which is kind of the
opposite of what a lot of people would
think
on their face
on the surface
yeah the idea of the advanced variation
in the karo khan is as we'll see for a
moment basically
the battle of idea says the bishop
actually on f5 is misplaced and i will
try to take advantage of this bishop on
f5 that's right the bishop on c8 is
poorly placed but if black can execute a
trade of the light squared bishops then
it's not a poor people
plenty of times myself now i think
another reason is that that pawn on d4
because we've already played c6 remember
yesterday we were talking about how if
in the french
we could firmly defend that pawn on d4
and play bishop d3 life would be lovely
yeah it's a dream position but um it
just turns out that tactically you get
to put so much pressure on that d4 pawn
that
we can't really play um in our ideal
fashion we have to make some concessions
really early on right to keep to
maintain the d4 pawn and the active
bishop whereas in the carol when you do
play c5 it is a second tempo with the c
pawn precisely that's the other point
bishop e2 this
system of course was made popular by
nigel short i called it the short
defense and he he was going to sue me
for libel uh
for those of you tuning in is that
white's not supposed to play a defense
white's supposed to play an attack
exactly i think uh actually i played uh
against antoinette stefanova one game
where she said something similar she
wasn't trying to be mean again it was
funny right um where i played like a g3
line against her famous scandinavian she
always used to play the scandinavia
and afterwards i got a pretty decent
position and somebody asked after the
game what do you think of the opening
and they're like it's a solid defense
nice
yeah exactly inappropriate for that
opening
for sure and what we have seen here by
var is var has indeed played the move c6
e5 and what you just
mentioned yourself is this is actually a
kind of a loss of tempo you see that c
pawn stutter stepping its way to c5 so
what white
does now i believe
he has done is castled
and what he does after the move knight
c6 i think all of these moves have been
played c2 c3 that wasn't the move that i
was about to
lead up to in a crescendo
white usually tries to take advantage of
a slightly superior development by
playing the move c2 c4 this is the most
challenging and blowing open the
position early
black's king on e8 notice very
importantly that all
the
pieces on the king side are still on the
original squares so it's going to take
black quite a number of moves to get us
king into safety on the king side in the
meantime meanwhile with the move c2 c4
white tries to blow up the position and
take advantage of a superior
lead in development c2c3 is a quiet move
just reinforcing the d4 pawn and asking
black exactly what he's going to do in
terms of his development
in my match with spassky this was the
approach that
boris took against me
but in truth i actually got a very good
position and i even won that game and i
won the match
i consider this move
less challenging than c3 c4 i'm sure sam
has some very specific reasons why he
chose that move well one interesting
thing about sam is that he's an e4
player for the most part but he doesn't
he must not like playing against the
french because i noticed in his two
games was white against var he's
actually played d4
so uh-huh that's uh very strange and uh
you know bobby fisher famously didn't
like playing against the french there's
a lot of e4 players who don't
like the french and he probably also
just thought that var was good at it so
right he deviated in those two games and
now he's going back in this critical
match for for version into his typical
e4
now
also for the uh us chess championship
you want to take a look at uh
our defending champion gotta kamsky yes
by all means let's
uh a crucial hit in the u.s is going to
be really big in my opinion because i
think that sam jacqueline is going to
really fight for the win in this game oh
with that
every player would but i think the clash
of styles here is likely to lead to a
really exciting contest well i mean sam
has the perfect opportunity to play the
role of spoiler
not a great outing i expected more from
sam in this tournament i'm sure
sam expected more of himself as well
but to defeat the uh tournament leader
is kind of a nice
uh secondary uh price exactly if he wins
he
redeems himself in the public eye to
some extent as
that is important especially i think
that's especially important to some of
the younger players they're like they
like the attention and they want to be
stars
of course feels good to win on on the
biggest stage i you know it's
interesting okay uh
got it today um
plays against mac mullener
mac's debut
not too much was expected from mack and
his debut
he's just happy to be here and compete
with the elites he probably would have
liked a better result
sergey arenberg but the players i'm
impressed with daniel naradiski
obviously daniels played an excellent
event
ray has got to be disappointed with his
performance sam's got to be disappointed
with
his performance both of those great
stars wanted to shine in this particular
field and again the olympic
spot is up for grabs assuming you know
it's not a reading um a lower rated
player wins the event and josh also
doctor
i mean that he really belongs here a
very solid result although not as young
as uh
the
true true it's kind of like more i think
he's uh probably about 29 something like
that yeah mid to late 20s yeah
but uh coming to the game returning to
the game of gotta kamsky let's just see
how that opening unfolded as we know god
has a reputation for slow playing and
yeah
slow playing it in the opening 27 years
old for josh d4 knight f3
and again
gada chooses a london system uh bringing
his bishop out here to the f four square
i remember i did this against dr john
nun john nunn was really famous for his
king's indian defense play and i said
okay i'm not going to go into the main
lines with john nunn and i brought my
bishop out to f4 as well he plays the
silver does she really good for her
thank you for helping the helping
teacher yeah that was so much fun at the
girl scouts exhibition h2h3 just a quick
explanation about this move
obviously the pawn uh dust protect the
g4 square but far more importantly what
white's intention is is to give this
bishop a retreat to the h2 square should
black ever challenge the bishop with the
move knight h5
so it's a kind of a preventive move or
sometimes d6 to e5 occurs and we play
bishop h2 in advance of that exactly d6
e5
uh the bishop again just has a nice
little comfortable home from the h2
square
so all of these moves are very standard
although bishop e2 is
okay
some debate about this move bishop e2
lots of folks including myself
prefer
knights before bishops as a principle
the reason why we
might want to play the move knight be d2
is because it it
stops it doesn't just discourage it
simply stops
the counter-attacking move queen b6
eyeballing this pawn on b2 because after
knight c4 not only does the knight
protect the pawn on b2 it attacks
black's queen black's queen just simply
loses a tempo so the idea of knight b to
d2 as opposed to the move that godda
played which was bishop e2 was to stop
queen b6 uh matt took advantage of the
of white's move order not surprisingly
he developed his queen and said hey
listen your pawn is under pressure i'm
going to take your pawn gotta stop that
with queen b3 and now i've always
thought that the move bishop c8 to e6
attacking white's queen was a good
equalizing move i think that gotta
although ghada likes these slow
positions and my goodness how many
players has he outplayed in positions
where he had no advantage uh
after the move bishop e6 i think black
is doing simply fine
comes out of the opening with a good
position but as you mentioned gadokamsky
is no stranger to
winning for but equal position is why
absolutely he just simply grinds and he
outplays his opponent just based on his
superior skill that's what it comes down
to
so yeah those are the critical gains we
have in the championship kamsky
mullener shankly nakobian and lenderman
nareditsky although there yes exactly
there was one other key game in the
championship that i did want to take a
quick look at it is the in the game
between alex lenderman who is in a tie
for second place he's playing uh going
up against daniel noroditzki
who
beats sam shanklin in this precise
uh opening of the king's indian defense
let's take it from the top just to see
how the players got to the situation
that they did
an english opening that quickly
transposed in the king's indian defense
again this is a an
exact replay of the game between
shanklin when shanklin was white and
naradity was black a game that
naraditsky won
captured on d4 played the move rookie 8
attacking the pawn on e4 provoking the
move f2 f3
knight c6 quickly by daniel
attacking this knight on d4 this gives
white an opportunity to do what he did
in the game which was capture and double
these pawns
now
it's it's one of those things we can
debate endless to the end of time are
these pawns weak the double pawns or are
they an asset in a sense this pawn on c6
is a key asset because it does control
the d5 and b5 squares
but it's all about the battle of ideas
queen d2
in that game between shanklin and
naraditsky we saw that uh noradiski
brought his bishop to e5 early he wanted
to come over here with queen h4
now that after queen d2
now that these uh
pawns are doubled there is a half open b
file so that the rook could swing over
to the b file and put pressure on this
pawn on b2 instead dano decided to lash
out in a different way with f7f5 perhaps
yes
okay i was about to say that it's it's
nice to put the rook on b8 you just want
to be sure you do it at a time that you
don't leave the a7 pawn
hanging
f7 f5 was in fact naraditsky's decision
attacking in the center
menacing
uh the possibility of bishop takes c3
and capturing twice on e4
also uh preparing to reroute his knight
and bring it back into the game the
players are still
deep into opening theory um i'm playing
very quickly and playing very quickly
i'm sure lindemann uh was well prepared
especially landerman yes he would have
expected he would have studied daniel's
games and expected to see this variation
on the board let me just get in
interesting and uh
kobien
okay
let me just get an up oops excuse me i
just wanted to get yeah rook d1 was
played as in in response to f7 f5 i
would expect to expect dania to retreat
his knight pardon me in the game
macobian kobe so there's been a capture
on d4 and uh sam has recaptured with the
knight right okay let's just go back a
quick second so this is where we saw
this move c2 c3
by um
sam shanklin i believe against boris
baskey i played the move bishop
f5 to g6 just preparing to play knight
h6 to f5 but that was not jacobian's
choice he resolved the tension in the
center with c5 takes d4 i don't like
this move i don't like this move for the
simple reason
that
keeping that tension
actually benefits black
and
after knight takes d4
a very nice recapture by the way
by sam there's
there's this
there's a hit against the bishop on f5
and if you play knight takes e5
knight takes f5
e takes f5 the theoreticians that spend
their lives studying openings have
determined that not only is this pawn uh
sacrifice good for white but black can
fall into a
big
mess
exactly
and that came very dangerous exactly is
still in the center of the board i'm
sure our tournament leader var wanted
nothing to do with that variation and so
he played a different move i believe he
captured the knight
either knight g7 or captures i bet yes
you're right he played knight ge7
knight ge7 protecting the knight as well
oop protecting this knight as well as
the bishop and remember we've been
talking about the dream position from
the french white has now nicely set up
his bishop on d3 without having the
problem of having to worry about
defending his d4 pawn on the other hand
he has now black has gotten rid of that
bishop which you mentioned was a target
but you like white hair yes i i just
think that white has a comfortable edge
here essentially from white's point of
view this pawn on e5 is a nice brick
wall in the center of the board and it's
very easy to deploy your pieces behind
this pawn so that's right i mean i think
that in this game kobe is not that well
prepared
i mean he didn't know what cherokee was
going to play and i'm sure he was
preparing for c3 c4 as opposed to c2 c3
so maybe it may be a nice surprise by uh
sam
from white's point of view white's moves
are very easy to to see rookie one
knight d2 knight f3 bishop f4 and just
play with the two bishops as well as an
edge in the center that's right if we
can get this position every time
it's a deal it's a deal it's a deal i
signed me up
again i just want to point out boldly
stating the obvious that you can't
capture this pawn in the middle of board
because after rook e1 black will have
issues
with his knight pinned to his king black
will lose a piece never worry i mean we
do have some newcomers to the broadcast
so
oh okay
we'll show you the pins and checkmates
exactly and then in a few weeks you'll
you'll know them cold and you can show
them to your uh your friends exactly
cycle of chess improvement
um we'd like to remind you all those you
out listening there whether you're just
starting out or you're really good
tweet us
at the hashtag u.s chess champs we are
going to be giving out prizes every day
from one of our sponsors chess.com for
the best question that adults give you
get a diamond membership to test.com and
juniors receive a gold membership to
chesskid.com you can also email us at
comments at st louis chessclub.org so
keep your questions and comments coming
and we've got a grand master maurice
ashley with some interesting tidbits
from the us women's championship
well jen sometimes it's better to be
lucky than good and somehow it seems
that the luck always goes to the strong
but not always the reason we got to
where we are today well a few key games
coming from the women's side in the
championships first of all this one
between irina crush and alyssa melahina
where
irina got to this position but in
terrific time pressure after the move
king to f6 she missed capturing on c5
here if she had simply captured on c5
then after this move what she truly
missed was this retreat king to h1 she
thought that she would have to capture
back and there'd be a perpetual check
but she missed this if she had found
this move she would have gained a full
point in round six of the competition
however instead of that she ended up
drawing this game and what happened
later in round six when everybody
thought this game was going to be a draw
anna zatonski
proved otherwise because her opponent
after she had been pressuring her for
over 100 moves
cracked and played this move rook to h1
and allowed the move knight to e7 check
king over well she resigned before
actually allowing rook to be eight mate
but arena should thank her lucky stars
as well because last round she played
against sabina foyser and this position
arrived on the board and all of us
everybody thought this is over all forza
has to start with is to move queen takes
exit h6 grabbing upon being up a free
pawn for no reason this king would just
be miserably placed she'd have to
grapple with a move like knight eight
six and then you could just castle and
smile away this position is totally
crushing for white instead foyzer
avoided that line ended up retreating
and having an even position and almost
was pressured not too much but later
might have even lost the game so irina
managed to draw so
both sides collecting half points that
they shouldn't have shedding half points
that they shouldn't have but it seems
like anna has been much more consistent
and it's arena with the up and down play
and chatting with her yesterday you
could see the disgust on her face she
really felt
disgusted with the way she has been
playing these championships but as a
champion she has to clear her head and
get into this game because all that
matters right now is the next few hours
may actually decide the women's
championships back to you guys thanks
maurice it's interesting how you meant
in luck and test because i also play
poker
and people are always asking me about
luck and chess and whether there is any
and i guess the answer is that not
exactly but yes
i always thought that there was luck in
chess
but that you make your own luck in other
words you can get lucky by correctly
guessing your opponents opponent's
state of uh
opening preparation correctly guessing
your opponent's state of mind in other
words if you if you think your opponent
is tired and is looking to make a draw
and to trade a lot of pieces you might
correctly guess that what you should be
doing is playing a long long battle so
there is luck and chess but unlike in
poker
all of the moves are visible your hands
are not hidden
and so uh the level of skill is
extraordinary high of course right in
poker you really need a lot of volume to
get that type of skill whereas
and the type of luck is even different
like it's like you could have made it at
least in chess even if you get lucky you
still have to make some decision
to capitalize on that
in poker you could have made all your
decisions and still get lucky exactly
all the wrong decisions and still get
lucky that's right so there's still a
lot of still a lot of similarity but it
comes down to having enough
volume right yeah and experience uh just
bringing up the game between uh ana
arena and anna again i i think that this
rival is just so intense one of the
great chess rivalries in u.s chess
history you can talk about sammy
rashevsky and bobby fischer and sammy
rachelski and ruben fine and frank
marshalls and
frank marshall and his contemporaries
but these two are going to really
absolutely they'll be they will be in
the hall of fame across the street and
those matches that they've played with
each other
have been so exciting uh i can just say
that what happened
will be another one purple versus pink
today when we got to this position
remember i was explaining anna went into
a deep think
because she has this opportunity of an
early capture on c4 she eschewed that
and went c7c5 castles knight c6 building
up a nice
pawn formation in the center
arena was quick
to play the move d2d4 which is a direct
transposition into a catalan takes on c4
queen a4 and this is a very famous
position out of the cattle and i
remember it very well in 1983 i was in
nick such yugoslavia i was playing in a
tournament with
soon to be world champion gary kasparov
against sweden's ultra-solid grandmaster
ulf anderson is black and ulf
went deliberately into an ending
that all of the pundits at that time had
said is simply better for white he
deliberately sacrificed his queen got to
this position
and played the move bishop d7 notice you
can't take the bishop because after
queen takes there's a double attack
against the king and the rook black
would be lost what grandmaster ulf
anderson did was play the move bishop d7
white
gary kasparov played rook to d1
basically the only move in the position
that
gives black any trouble black gave up
his queen for a rook a bishop and pawn
and graham and olf anderson drew the
soon-to-be world champion very easily
very very easily with the black pieces
and and gary was disgusted because he
was hoping
that that this position what all the
theoreticians said was good for for for
white ended very easily drawn by olf
well it's interesting that you say
disgusted because i think that that's
the thing about irena crush she loves
to play really good chess it's not just
a competition it's also really an art
form for her and it's about truth and
finding the right moves in the position
absolutely exactly and i think that's
more of her and then anna's a little bit
more of the warrior so that's one of the
reasons why arena crusher is
disappointed not just her score but in
her play with the play that's right kind
of like yesterday with you
when you saw these various moves being
played like king takes c6 instead of bc6
you could see that you were physically
in pain yeah this made me like to see
bad testimonies no no that's exactly
what a great story i remember this very
well it was in the 1990 world chess
championship in new york city and lyon
and a chess legend former world champion
michael tall misha had just got taken a
flight from moscow to new york city call
it a 12 hour 13 hour flight
got into taxi rushed to the uh macklo
hotel the mackloth theater where the
game was being played came into my suite
where i was doing a chess commentary
just sat down completely exhausted the
game was in progress gary kasparov was
on pressing and on the attack he
literally looked up at the screen and
we're all looking at michael tol he had
our attention he's looking at this the
the screen uh
kasparov made a move and instantly
doll's face twisted as if he had just
eaten the worst tasting frog of his life
and it was like physical pain reaction
completely jet lag instantly understood
that gary had made a bad move and
everybody in the room quickly looked at
the monitor to see what the blunder was
the escargot variation the escargot
variation i mean the hot pepper
variation whatever it was yeah so anyway
uh yeah it's sometimes it is painful to
watch when the players are under such uh
stress and pressure they can make bad
moves
or watching a time scramble it's both
fun but it's also just really
it's like
it's painful at the same time watching
like all the pressure especially if you
know one of the players and your friends
and you have a rooting interest but even
if not right
we love it too right and
we're sure to see some of that in this
crucial matchup chris statonski let's
take a quick commercial break and we'll
be back for more from the championship
and women's here in st louis
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess hall of fame in st louis
is nothing you'd expect and everything
you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together
the world chess hall of fame
mind art experience
i love that clip you always see somebody
new in it i just spotted women's world
former world champion alexander
christina front row and i also spotted
our current guest
gene hoffman the executive director at
the united states chess federation was
also in that awesome chess is clip that
we just saw and she is with grandmaster
maurice ashley to talk about her new
position at the uscf she became
executive director
in november remember we had frank
guadalupe on the sink field cup just as
she was getting elected for this new
position wonderful and she's with
maurice to talk about the future of
chess in america
thanks jen i'm with gene hoffman the
executive director of the us chess
federation gene welcome to our show
thank you it's great to be here
gene uh what is it like to be a partner
with this
this club uh this city these
championships it's fantastic we are so
honored to be here and so excited to be
part of what's becoming a wonderful
tradition for chess in the united states
um there's so many opportunities to
enjoy chess here yeah and it's a great
time now that there's the opportunity
for
um the
uh city to be named the capitol yeah
that's pretty cool very cool no question
about it that's never happened uh in
history so you it's great to be the the
executive director under uh that that
little bit of history making on chess
tell us uh what's been happening at the
uscf i understand you guys have a new uh
status we just got our 501c3 status um
we're really excited about that it's
part of what i would say has been um in
the making for a couple of years in
terms of the organization really
promoting um
chess as an educational tool and
promoting chess throughout the united
states now speaking of an educational
tool you just had all your scholastic
championships the high school the middle
school and the elementary school
nationals sounded like there were a lot
of kids who played in those events there
were we had
really high numbers we
almost ran out of space at the junior
high nationals
dallas had great numbers in spite of any
uh some weather issues people still
showed up and enjoyed the chess it was
wonderful
indeed
tell us we also have a partnership i may
add my millionaire chess event with the
us chess federation tell us a little bit
about that well we're really excited to
promote the millionaire chess
tournament it's really great opportunity
for chess in the united states it's we
want to be a part of things that
are help growing trust new for chess and
it's a huge opportunity to get chess out
there thank you so much it should be a
lot of fun so any other initiatives we
should know about should expect from the
from the federation uh going into the
summer
um we are just doing our executive board
meeting right now and so we're in the
middle of coming up with some new i
think programs new things so be on the
lookout
indeed we will thank you so much for
joining us gene thanks for having me
best of luck with the rest of your your
uh plans for the future of the u.s chess
floration thank you gene hoffman the
executive director of the u.s chess
federation overseeing all that is chess
in the united states
visiting us here at the championships
back to you guys
that's right uh actually uh jean and i
have known each other for many years we
even started the organization buying
queens together wow that's where jean
got she was the executive director of
that organization as well okay
okay wonderful well i of course became a
uscf member back when i was 12 during
the bobby fischer era
and the united states chess federation
is responsible for raiding all the
tournaments played in the united states
deciding the olympiad helping the
elementary
junior high high school championships
these u.s championships running those
events supporting but uh the champions
national scholastics in the spring those
are really the hallmark events of the us
jazz federation and then the olympia
teams uh men's and women's or women's
and open as well as the world team
championships so the uscf just does a
lot
a lot of chess and there's prison chess
and correspondence chess it just goes on
and on and on so it's a real
um
big task that the uscf performs and they
certainly have
had and will have my support
for as long as i'm here well now they're
501c3 which is really great they were
previously they were a not-for-profit
organization but a 501c3 helps make any
any
gifts uh a deductive
tax deductible right on your federal
return so
also precisely and the 501c3 as well and
now where
the st louis is a educational entity as
well which is even a different
subcategory of a 501c3 but it's great to
see the uscf making that step and i
think it's a real step forwards and
she's also the first female executive
director which is nice is she really is
she really well that's also a
breakthrough too so
there's
chess we do have a question actually a
related question
from our twitter feed or hashtag u.s
chess champs old school soul asks
why are there still separate ratings for
men and women turned into gm via gm
well as we pointed out many times in the
gra the broadcast actually irena crush
has earned her grandmaster title just
recently
and a lot of the women in the tournament
prefer to go buy their regular fide
titles if you will and not their women's
titles so it's kind of like an optional
thing really you can get the title but
you don't necessarily have to use it
if that makes any sense like for
instance tata of abrahamia and i know
that she's going to use her im title
when she gets that alyssa malaquina uses
her feed a master title even though she
also has the women's international
master title i see was the question
about ratings or titles
well because there's no separate ratings
the women and the men
everybody has and part of the rating
pool but titles are different and the
titles really were used as a device to
really encourage
girls and women to play chess and to
give them
titles that were a little the bar was
set a little bit lower but they could
get titles and many women including
for example arena crush have gotten
their overall grandmaster title as well
exactly it used to be a really small
number but now i think it's almost 20.
yeah it's just exploded so it's really
uh
i i think that it's a controversial
issue and that i i do think that
eventually the titles will be phased out
but i think people fixated on a little
bit and most chess players are mostly
interested in your chess rating so don't
get hung up on it doesn't mean that uh
the players themselves or
any of the organizers are anti-feminists
just because they use the wtm title in
the end these players are rated not or
not invited not by their titles by the
ratings and again just a recognition for
the outstanding achievements they have
made i i don't have any problem at all
personally with the titles and anything
that encourages uh women and girls to
play chess i strongly support by the way
just in saying i mean i the game between
arena and anna i know
uh
big big matches all over the place but
that game really has my whole uh
attention for this uh crucial round for
the women's championship for the women's
championship and indeed by the way ana
zatonski has gone into that line that i
had shown a moment ago
the queen sacrifice that was essayed by
olf anderson essentially black has two
moves in this position after bishop d7
black ends up getting split pawns on the
queen side i like white's chances and
that
variation queen takes d4 is the money
move rook uh pardon me bishop c bishop
takes c6 check bishop d7 this was the
that that ending i talked about a moment
ago or late middle game if you will
where black sacrifices
her queen for rook bishop and pawn but
that bishop on c6 is simply excellent
and oftentimes it takes white
a few moves to
win this pawn
by bringing her knight around for
example a move like knight d2 rook d1
queen c2 b5 this type of thing
lots and lots of trades and again ulf
anderson was
able to make a draw against soon-to-be
world champion gary kasparov and
obviously a draw in this
situation would be ideal for anna other
than the
the win but that's even asking more than
what she really needs to draw is what
she really needs to to clinch at least a
tie for first although she was careful
to point out yesterday that playing for
a draw could be extremely dangerous it's
true playing yeah you don't want to do
that uh
clearly
so
let me just go and move somebody has not
been
listening to your coverage because they
said why is hannah zatonski taking so
long on her eighth move isn't bishop d7
more or less forced
queen takes d4 is the main main
alternative
on our first board in the
open section
we
not too much has happened since we la
last left it we're about these parts
bishop d3 had been played
var bishop c5
knight d2 as mentioned i think white's
ideal set up is simply to bring his
knight to c3 his bishop to f4 develop
his queen side control the center and
hope to use the two bishops
to get a significant edge
if white manages all of those moves sam
will have a considerable advantage so
var will certainly be aware of that and
not want to play
um uh too cautiously
although we've seen var on the defensive
before in this tournament against correa
and he uh he really fought back well so
he's a fighter and i think this game uh
he's going to to to hold down the fort
as best as he can of course of course
he's not going to choke
if he loses it'll be because of sam's
energetic play that is true that is true
he's not going to give up the point
easily yeah
we got another question coming in to
hashtag u.s chess champs james baxley
asks could you explain the difference
between a strong gm and a regular gm
isn't it insulting not to call a gm
strong
or i think he means redundant right
right and maybe a strong jihab is is
that redundant well i
no it kind of goes backwards and
forwards first for a quick second um
i think
really instead of using the world's word
strong
what grandmasters themselves like to use
is to say world class
there are about 1200 1300 grand masters
in the world
and when we think of world-class players
we're really thinking in terms of the
world's top 100 players those players
who really have a legit
shot at one day becoming a world
champion so we
tend to use the term grand masters as
well as world class grand master's just
a slight distinction it's not meant as
an insult to anybody
and uh there's a site the very popular
site
2700chess.com which shows you
all grandmasters over that crucial 2700
mark the world-class grand masterpiece
carlson better buy that url 2900
chess.com and then
just be one player right when he gets
there exactly
kind of like patrick riley's three-peat
the nba world championship miami heat
winning three title as an la lakers
patrick reilly the coach patented the
word
three-pete
magnus is going to have to patent 2 900.
2900 chess.com that's right but um
seriously we do have uh he card knocking
work who's number seven in the world
this moment you can check that on
3700test.com and i also got some word
from michael klein over at chess.com who
says that nakamura was playing against
jan elvis yesterday
in a one minute bullet match against
janet no against evan joo who's by the
way one of the best bullet players on
the site so
young guy
not super high rated only in fm but
considered to be a fantastic bullet
player now i want you guys to guess the
score
and meanwhile we're gonna head on over
how many games did they play they played
168 games be serious try to guess the
score
so 168 times like one and a half i guess
an average of one and a half minutes a
game or something wow that's a serious
head-to-head match okay 107 168 games
nakamura you guess maurice gas and then
i'll tell you what the answer is but
first let's uh
see what maurice ashley has to say about
this young medical event game
that's crazy first of all i don't have
to really think about that one but
nakamura is a beast he's incredible at
bullet so that might skew your guesses
folks but we all know that he's simply
the best in the world he's just
incredible but just going to some
research in this position
i looked up some games
in the database and then found that in
this position
anan himself a former world champion
champion vishwanathan anand and
candidate for the title against carlson
this year has been in this position with
black and he played the move bishop to
e7 and that has been the more popular
move in this position bishop to e7 the
other move that i found is to move g6
here uh preparing potentially to get the
bishop here but also just strengthening
the knight itself move bishop c5 that
was played by a cobian that move has
only been essay twice at least that i
found in the date in our database here
not the most popular movie not played at
the highest level so sam was probably
not expecting the smooth bishop to c5
and it looks as though he very quickly
played the natural move knight to d2
anyway which is part of this formation
actually the the move queen e2 would
have i'm sorry bishop to e7 would have
forced queen e2 to defend this pawn
because the bishop blocks any pin along
this file but bishop c5 leaves white
comfortably without having to worry
about this pawn at the moment because
you still cannot capture it because
bishop c5 creates bishop f5 creates too
much worry after rook to e1 so this move
bishop c5 i'm not sure if varusian felt
uh that he was playing a novelty or he's
happy with the move but it certainly is
not the most popular move in this
position and as you can see there he's
intensely looking at the board while sam
is just kind of sitting back relaxed
knowing that he's in a pretty good
position guys
thank you maurice so this is actually a
popular situation for
uh caro khan players uh capturing on d4
i was critical of that move i didn't
realize that my colleagues actually like
to play this position because again
in that game on on our first board
between sam and var it seems to me that
white
plays essentially for free
once white is able to bring his let's
let's just put some moves on the board
for a moment let's just imagine castles
knight f3 from white's point of view
white just wants to build up his
uh forces behind this pawn on e5 and
there's not really any targets in the
position for black to attack
in fact
it's probably in black's best interest
to try to play a move like knight h4
wanting to trade knights but you got to
be careful always about these types of
bishop
sacrifices
where the queen can come out here and
black's king is
kind of loosely dangling in the wind so
to speak so i see a position that's
easier for
white to play and that black has to be
very
precise
in his moves uh to
find counter chances in the position
it's really not that easy in my view uh
to play black that's right i mean it's a
dream to have the white bishop on d3 and
upon e5 that's what we kept saying that
we wanted to do yesterday uh if we were
writing against the french and that's
why alyssa ended up sacrificing that
pawn ana zatonski
great preparation and won the game but
you know today it's not as if he's so
well prepared because she's actually
been thinking she said don't she's been
thinking for almost 20 minutes on that
position about queen takes d4
really
very very very odd because first of all
her husband daniel friedman grandmaster
uh i think that they could have expected
the catalan as a very reasonable guess
choice by irina crush and so to have
this position on the board why she's
taking so long
i don't get that uh that's uh
that's just not professional she should
she should in this moment be whipping
out queen takes d4 and not spending so
much time i don't like the variations
with bishop d7 those lines of play are
just simply easier for white
and maurice has something for us in
another game in the women's championship
well not a significant game but a
significant moment in the game between
sabine sabina foser and victoria knee
and these two players are not doing so
great at the championships right now
sabino with white doing a bit better
than me but it turns out that black
right now can virtually win a pawn
because if it's avoided she will get a
dominant position it looks as if white
has really messed up this formation
she's put her bishop on a3 she's got
pieces jumbled on the queen side not
really coordinated but most importantly
her d-pawn is not that well placed and
right now black could play the move
knight to d to e6 hitting the d4 pawn
and it's not that easy to defend notice
of course that this bishop chased his
knight away so he cannot go back over
here how do you defend the pawn if you
advance it then the knight simply lands
on the d4 square anyway and your queen
is relegated to more horrible squares on
this side don't forget this bishop on
this long diagonal by the way so you
don't want to put your queen on b2 and
find itself in that bishop's glare well
a move like queen c1 is also not that
great because of this move knight to h5
and now this knight is headed toward the
f4 square not easy to stop all this by
the way don't make any crazy moves
trying to chase this bishop out because
all of a sudden will show up a sacrifice
if you accept this knight to f4 and
suddenly queen g5 and mate threats
against a strip naked king it's just
horrible over here with all these pieces
clustered on this side
black is simply crushing white in this
position no way to even think about
playing anymore in this game really bad
situation that white has found herself
in in only
what looks like 13 moves
terrible position for white she's going
to be challenged if this move 96 lands
on the board guys
totally agree that looks like a terrific
idea
96 and 94
black seizing the initiative
very early in that one
and another game
i've picked up
on board two between alex lenderman and
daniel naraditsky after daniel got in
the f7 f5 break it looks to me like he's
got a very comfortable position with
black and daniel will be very happy with
what happened we'll just go back a
second to see how we did get here we did
see this move f7 f5 attacking the pawn
on e4
lenderman played
f3 knight back to f6 bishop d3 takes
takes and we're seeing a wholesale like
trades
if
lenderman went for
a line like trading all of these pieces
these pawns on the kings on the
queen side and in the center are not not
weak and i think that
black is actually just simply equalized
in this position so daniel naraditsky
looks like his king's indian defense
keeps holding up in these u.s
championships the king's indian defense
has a reputation of being
a risky uh opening a risky defense
exceeding white too much space but
daniel has just played
very easily in his games as black and
has done very well with his favorite
defense
and we do have some moves in the women's
championship
96 was played by victoria v
and anna zatonski did go in for that
line with queen takes d4 but not without
thinking for about 20 minutes before she
did it yeah and again i just like talk
talk talk bad bad bad uh
you know sometimes you get this luxury
like you know obviously ana can actually
move very very very quickly when
motivated to do so yeah we saw some
evidence of that earlier wow isn't that
spec wasn't that dramatic by the way
that one of the greatest
showdowns of armageddon playoffs we
we've seen on video
uh but sometimes that can lull you into
a false sense of security so much so
that you badly mismanage your time so
i'm one of those that you know if you
know what opening you're going to play
and just play it just get to a position
and and conserve that time for when
a critical moment arrives down uh the
road so we have seen uh rook d one i
assume we are seeing queen takes d1 now
or
has anna played that move not yet anna
has not yet
take c6 instead ah this is an end game
that uh and after queen takes c6bc6 rook
d4 yeah this is an end game that uh
vladimir kramnik absolutely loves to
play with white
and um he's been very successful black's
two blacks
split pawns on the queen side promises
white a very very comfortable long-term
edge
not easy to win of course but black is
suffering needlessly i don't like this
choice at all by
her
anna
right yeah she really is seizing the
defensive and playing it uh too
passively in my opinion and she's giving
arena a free hand
to try to press an advantageous end game
against her not a wise decision in my
view maybe she didn't know about this
variation that's what you would think
right then shame on her twice
she really should be very familiar with
that queen sacrifice because it's a
classic
and gary kasparov has talked about it in
his books and in many many interviews of
what a great
impact impression that had on his career
that he was unable to win that game
against ulf speaking of discussing um
you know studying the classic games what
did you think did you come up with a
number for me in the nakamura i do i'm
going to say 102 for nakamura
out of 168.
we got another try from diagramworthy on
twitter he said 150 games for nakamura
the truth was 160 wins and eight losses
the guy the guy evangel was rated 2700
in bullich ass
what a domination by hacaro i thought
the guy was a rival that doesn't that
sounds like a wipeout that is a wipeout
indeed oh my i was going to guess 120 by
the way i felt i felt nakamura i know
nakamura is incredible but 160. ah
well here's the question i don't even
lose eight actually
if you can 160.
he shouldn't be losing at all but how
could the fellow
withstand a hundred and sixty losses i
mean that's like being beaten like a
drum i mean at some point you gotta say
time out i quit i quit i quit is he
gonna get to play nakamura in in bullen
you know he's one of the best bullet
players on test.com he probably sees it
as a great
it might not opportunity
itself of course it i i understand i
understand but you can only take so much
i mean i agree with you yes
i remember i remember once i played
roman general joshua when i was a
up-and-coming player i wasn't even an im
not title but of course the great genji
was a gm and we played ten five-minute
games i mean five-minute blitz
and the score was 10-0 he beat me every
single game
once we were about 7-0 i felt like i was
never going to win the game and then we
got to 10-0 and the brain is just mush
after that right i want to play this guy
you're right you're better than me right
now
i get it i mean later we would only play
one over the board game when i was
getting my first gm norm and we drew
that game by then i'd gotten better but
boy did he give me a lesson and it's
really hard i can't imagine nakamura
winning game after game after game what
are you thinking when he wins game 100
okay okay stop
you know respect you're right incredible
that's an incredible uh score and also
incredible that the guys just stuck
through it wow i mean in boxing they
have trainers that throw in the towel
yeah
i
you know from serious brain damage a
hundred and sixty to eight oh my wonder
it could be pretty addictive i it is it
it sure it sure is losing 160 games
i'm sorry
even addicts don't go for that
that's some form of masochism i don't
understand it wow wow
okay
so get your award-winning skills uh
beefed up guys listen listening out
there okay and actually those games are
archived if you want to study the
intricacies of the one-minute match
they're on chess.com oh there's a
library of games very cool classics
someone made a game see if you can tell
you know it would be fun fun to show
tactics from classics and one minute
games and see if you could tell the
difference like how many
how many you figured out like you don't
have to solve the position you have to
say whether it's a bullet or a classic
right or rapid or something like that
right that would be really fun that
would be crazy and we actually uh have
for you guys a real classic fisher oscar
um oscar pano and that's from buenos
aires 1970 and
um
once again you were challenged to find
the correct move for bobby fischer and
while you guys saw that we're going to
be taking a little break and we'll be
back for more from the u.s championship
and u.s women's championship here in st
louis
so
and did you guys all figure out how
fisher reeled that went in
maurice ashley has
the
finale for us
indeed jen this one was actually uh
a little bit complicated the way he got
here and the position that was was put
in front of you was a position that
surely showed the ending so we'll go
back a couple of moves to show how
fisher handled himself in this position
he's played the spectacular move
bishop to e4 so when i saw that diagram
i was like isn't isn't this from some
famous game and it was against oscar
pano in buenos aires official played
this amazing move bishop to e4 you dare
not touch this piece because you're
going to simply get wiped out after
knight takes and here comes the knight
into f6 and then he's going to rip off
on h7 and that's going to be all she
wrote so the real spectacular move the
real find is bishop e4 that's what makes
this position fischeresque the can the
game continue with queen to e7
and then knight takes h7 another
spectacular shot by fischer i believe uh
in this position
houdini was suggesting something like
knight to f5 but that
that's not going to work out sorry let's
just stick to what fischer did knight
takes on h7 a big time move and now
knight takes knight and then pawn takes
pawn and the attack the beauty of this
position is how the attack just flows
naturally there's nothing that black can
do to deal with a knight showing up on
the h5 square if you try to bring your
queen anywhere close
then simply bishop takes it seven queen
takes and queen takes e6 check picks off
the knight on c8 and that's going to be
all she wrote so it means that there's
nothing you can do to change this
cluster of white pieces and particularly
this knight going to this square his
opponent played knight g5
knight h5 and now it's just over and
knight's coming into f6 that's going to
cost your queen a couple of moves just
to be
desperate here knight h4 check king to
g3 knight takes on g6 knight f6 check
and after king to f7 queen h7 check and
there's only one move here his opponent
resigned rather than face this finish by
fischer so beautiful moves bishop to e4
also knight h7
take a look at fisher pano the whole
game it's a great kings indian attack
that bobby fischer specialized in
something you might want to add to your
game back to you guys
thanks maurice that's right we saw data
kamsky win a critical game here in the
u.s championship against lenderman who
he's not tied with in the rankings right
and that was also in the king's indian
attack that's a beautiful model by uh
bobby fischer i just have to say that's
very nice and i picked up on the game
between godda kamsky and mack
mullener and
it's kind of funny it brings back
memories myself gotta has a dream
position as white this is absolutely the
best that white could ever achieve out
of a london system and remarkably back
in belgrade
i think in the uh
um
boy i'm
having to guess which year it is
but it was a tournament in belgrade
where i had exactly this pond structures
white against gada
and i had them cold
totally winning position goddess
swindled me for a draw
i still remember that and
god has said what did i do wrong i got
this horrible position and we looked at
it in the post-mortem and i was showing
him
why this position is just so very good
for white
the real issue is this pawn on c5 with
this pawn on c5 it's it's a constant
it's constantly under threat it's a it
stands out like a sore thumb bishop e3
that would provoke the move b7 b6 and
then white can bring his rook to a6
castle
kingside double rooks on the a file and
although it doesn't look it
in truth uh
max position
is really close i mean really on the
edge of simply strategically lost that
is to say black doesn't have to make any
more mistakes
from this position i'm expecting gotta
reel in the point from here in a smooth
kamsky-like fashion and that is going to
put real pressure on ocobian our
tournament leader as we go into
tomorrow's key match-up between our
leaders so i'm thinking god is going to
win this game and let me just go to our
tournament leaders game in as a matter
of fact to see how that game has
unfolded we'll go back a move or two
when we had left it we've left it after
that move bishop c5 instead of the move
bishop e7
uh g7 g6 and knight f3 uh was played
right away
i'm not sure if i like this move knight
f3 so much i think that i would have
prefaced the move knight f3 with the
move queen e2
and
in short what i want to say is i don't
want to allow a trait of knights
sam
didn't feel that that was important so
you're saying that if you had your queen
on e2 and then you played knight f3
knight h4 you could have you don't have
to trade knights i can move my knight to
g5 or some some someplace else he went
knight f3 right away and i think that
this was a very crafty and deep
uh
in my opinion jacobian chose good
understanding by by playing knight h4
and wanting to trade off this night
which is the defender of the pawn on e5
uh and he did that quickly
okay yeah
rookie one was two takes up three queens
and i'm still not saying i'm not saying
that sam doesn't have an edge i really
do believe he does have an edge after
all sam has coaxed this move g7 g6 the
bishop is ready to
play bishop h6 and and control all of
those dark squares over there and here
again i'm kind of thinking that maybe
the bishop on c5 is misplaced and what
maurice was saying we understand that if
the bishop was on e7 black would have a
move like bishop g5 now that the bishop
is on c5 jacobian still a long way from
equality in this game and sam's got an
edge and he can feel that godda is
breathing down his neck on war ii that's
right a very comfortable position for
white but you feel that the more pieces
that are traded the closer
the greater whites advantage would be
right he would like to have more pieces
in this position than fewer now by the
way the names right here are are wrong
uh this is actually the game shankland
of erosion ocobian exactly
and we do have uh a guest with us now
we've got grandmaster robert hess who's
also with the sports quotient and you
know i heard something interesting that
he was up late last night not partying
no rather watching the 170 game bullet
match so maybe he can give us some
insight on what he learned from
nakamura's bullet tirade in addition to
the insights in these games
thanks jen with grand master robert hess
of the sports quotient uh junior at yale
now just finished my junior just
finished her junior year and uh big
basketball fan big sports fan fellow new
yorker of course so glad to have you on
the show thanks maurice so
you were up watching
168 games is that real
let's not let jen fools i was also
watching sportscenter at the same time i
was with mike klein i had my laptop open
but hikaru was playing evan drew on
chess.com they played like a hundred and
eight almost 180 games and a car only
lost eight of those games yeah we heard
it just is that mind-boggling yeah it
was crazy and mike and i were just like
is this a joke i mean he's just that
good you know there's no stopping him he
is just that good incredibly fast he
grew up on a steady diet of that did you
do that when you were a kid play all
those blitz games not really i mean
definitely played on icc and now playing
chess.com bunch but definitely not too
much blitz and i've always used a touch
pad so it's not good for bullet chests
no not at all he must pre-move
like crazy
the hand speed the mouse speed and he's
he's insanely good at bullets it's
unbelievable indeed indeed uh incredible
player well
take us you've been commentating over at
lester's with grandmaster ben feingold
you know you got the cushy job you got
the food coming all the time and you get
to talk to the fans there it's a great
live scene
tell us what you find interesting so far
in our top games let's start with
shanklin versus uh kobian yeah you know
at first shanghai was blitzing out the
opening and it looked really good for
him he plays the karakan as black so i
thought psychologically that would be a
good choice for shanklin to be facing it
and then black made a very weird
structure with bishop to c5 and then
went g6 i was thinking if he's gonna go
to g6 he goes first g6 and puts the
bishop on g7 so i think the bishop from
the wrong diagonal white is a slight
advantage and he's just gonna press for
the rest of the game yeah this move
bishop c5 was unusual but then to add g6
as you said seems very strange let's go
to the person chasing him the four-time
us champion godakomski what do you think
about his position yeah i you know he's
played this system so many times he's
beaten so many great players in the
system but i actually don't like his
position that much i think black is
perfectly fine and if the person playing
white were in godakomsky back over
lester's ben and i would be like wha
what is white doing but because it's
gotta and he's so strong we see him
we're like well you know white has this
going for him and this going for him but
in reality i think black isn't perfectly
fine mcmullen is playing very solidly
and he should be happy yasha sherman
says he's dead lost uh it's black
virtually
i'm surprised yesterday would say that
because they're he loves squares and
over here on the king side looks like
black is the one with the nice bishop
coming and the squares are a little weak
on the white king did you think g5 was
maybe too much of a concession in this
position yeah i definitely did i thought
actually maybe the knight would have
come to h5 and not be worried about and
later bishop takes h5 and weaken the
pawn structure because in the position i
think black needs to be a bit active but
still there are not that many weaknesses
for black so this game is imagining a
very long time but black so far i think
is set up well okay some controversy
among our leading grandmasters here
let's try another position crush
zatonski now this position
yasser was recommending the end game
that famous end game of kasparov uh
playing against off anderson but instead
she has opted for a line which really
now this move f5 we hadn't seen this
looks terrible for black yeah it's
really not a good position for black
however i think it's sometimes hard to
uh show your advantage and i think both
players are very well aware that white
is better here but to win this game and
that's what crush has to do
that will be very difficult to prove
that advantage with every move steadily
increasing that edge because in a few
moves if white's not careful block can
become close to the equality not
necessarily equalize but with every move
that's not improving the position black
has chances to come back and fight why
do you say that about this particular
position well because the square and d5
will be important for the black knight
so if you know you allow me to take on
e4 if you take an f5 d my now have this
d5 squared to penetrate with and it's
look at white's queen side it's
underdeveloped not saying black is well
developed we see everything is kind of
in the beginning position but still if
white doesn't prove quickly that
initiative then black can maybe unravel
and maybe some point sacrifice a pawn
again to a drawn like rook ending
exactly but i was thinking that this c
pawn may not be long for the world but
it's two against one right may not be so
easy to win when all the pieces of
trade-off traded off especially with the
black king ready to fight back so yeah
not great start for her but she's
clearly fighting for a draw here well
she's fighting for a draw but i also
think it's perfect for uh irena crush
because she needs to win we all know
that but she also doesn't have realistic
chance to lose his position it's not a
double-edged position where she'll
overpress and just lose because she's
trying so hard to win so it's really a
safe choice for her and i don't think
either player was prepared for this
opening at all they seem to be spending
a lot of time and i don't think they
have played this position with either
color so i was very surprised to see it
but definitely bodes well in uh crush's
favor indeed and let's look let's take a
look at another game if this listen to
me uh this game you ramirez honest joke
it just kind of jumped out at your eyes
when i when you first sat down and it
looks as though black is down a pawn but
you feel that actually this is worse for
white oh i definitely do it's funny
because we we're looking at lessers all
of a sudden this move knight takes d5
happened i think uh right over here and
we see well wait black's missing a pawn
on d5 however if we look there aren't
that many good squares for the white
pieces and how the game's gone on in the
given position black has a simple plan
of rook to d8 rook to ea this e2 pawn
might not last long this queen can come
over to h3 followed by knight g4 looking
very risky on this side of the board
that bishop on b6 is eyeing f2 and
dominating this knight the v3 that mp3
is is not a good piece and i've always
heard the saying about knights on b3 b6
g6 and g3 that once they're there they
often don't move again and i i'm
wondering when the next time that
knight's gonna move again so i think
despite being down a pawn black has a
pretty good position and great fighting
chances for a win indeed i love this
position with black uh you know me in
open position
compensation that's what i love and uh
finally let's take a look at uh a
critical game between lindeman and
nareditsky lindeman is chasing ocobian
at the moment and looks as though
naradiski
looks like he has
equalized maybe slight work site
weakness on the queen side yeah you know
it's funny because early on lenin was
playing instantly every move was bang
bang bang bang then a couple of moves in
a row neroditsky spent a lot of time
early on and then his responses were
very quick snap snap snap snap and now
it looks like narratives he's out of it
i think that's been the trend in the
tournament for lenderman he's been
playing some very good chess but in
games when he's out of his element he
starts spending time spending his time
and you can tell when his position is uh
becoming worse than it was a couple of
moves ago his game with shanklin was
just like that instead of blitzing at
the opening he spent a lot of time and
shanklin you know as we saw played a
nice game and beat him fairly easily but
here already i think black has equalized
his a4 move at the right moment to
weaken the white queen side and you know
there aren't as many threats as there
were a couple of moves ago the knight
became a d3 it could have maybe been an
e4 it was there a couple moves ago this
bishop on f2 doesn't really have a great
future so
if we just look at the minor pieces
maurice which bishop would you rather
have you know what i want
this one right here this baby on g7
beautiful
well what's the over and under on this
tournament what do you think about uh
ocobian's chances of actually winning
the swimming is a point ahead uh maybe
not in a great position now you said
komski is not doing that brilliantly and
lenderman's not doing that brilliantly
what's your opinion there's three rounds
to go and kobian still has to play
komski and linderman right so that's the
interesting part so
jacobian has been playing great chess
you start with four solid draws nothing
spectacular then he ripped off four wins
in a row his position may not be that
great right now but he's still fighting
and he still has a great chance to make
a draw in this game but really it's got
an alexa trying to come from behind but
don't also forget about neroditsy and
friedel their point and half coming into
this round but if they can string
together some wins even though they're
lower rated they can also compete for
the title but you have to like vars
chances here he is white against god in
the next round you know we don't want to
jump ahead because let's say
uh kobe somehow loses this game and god
wins that changes the whole nature of
the tournament but if
you know kobe is solid and draws and
let's say even if comps he wins he's
still a half point behind and he does
have to face komsey and leonard who are
both you know really hungry for this
title so it's everything is unclear but
i do have to favor kobe 10 just because
he has more points okay so give me
specific numbers uh 40 chance of winning
60 chance of winning eighty percent
chance
i would definitely say it's on the lower
side under 50. um that's not real
committal robert
you're asking me to commit a lot here
maurice um no i would say probably
somewhere like 30
30 yeah and and what would you give
komski's chances of winning this
tournament see they play next round it's
that's the key battle you know at this
point at this stage in the term that's
the real key battle and you know if
compsey beats him then that changes the
whole tournament so
um 30 seems like he seems low the worst
of hedging better yeah you know i i'm
actually about to raise that you know
you know you call my bluff and i'm gonna
have to i don't have to raise that i
think probably somewhere in maybe around
50 60 you know and the more i think
about it the more thing about he is a
point up and there are three rounds left
unless we see a total collapse which can
happen considering the strong players
he's playing um
it's hard he's playing so well i think
that he has a great chance of of
competing and winning this tournament
before i let you go i'm going to give
you assassin a chance to uh
to get in on this question yes what do
you think about this number is it is it
30 is it 50 is it 60.
how are these chances of winning the
tournament whoa whoa whoa whoa we'll
time out let's go back you have varico
being a one point lead with three games
to go
um
you can't give them 30. i i mean i'd say
55
and everything uh with i'll agree with
robert on one point uh the game tomorrow
is going to be a huge game uh between
var and godakamsky that could very well
decide the outcome but i'm thinking that
because varus played very well
he's got a one-point lead he's got a
better than 50 percent chance of
becoming the new u.s champion and before
you saw his position today you might
even give him more than that i mean his
position seems like a little bit worse
than what you would expect for just a
random black position well robert hit
that one two on the head if you're going
to play the position with g7 g6 put your
bishop on g7 don't put it on bishop on
c5 so vars giving himself some problems
i'll strongly disagree about uh i think
that
that
zatanski's made a very very poor choice
i think that that arena is delighted
with the situation she's in a must-win
situation but i think her advantage is
really very big and i think goddess
advantage is simply huge
one more question for robert for those
of you out there trying to improve your
one-minute skills yeah what do you think
you what what is it that you learned
from the match like is there any kind of
like tidbit i know you were doing a few
multitasking but
i mean any there was
there was there was talking
there was sports banging down good moves
as well
all right that's the secret he's fast
and he's good
i don't think it's much of a secret yeah
i have to replicate that i'm trying to
train him for that at home i don't know
i think he has years and years of
experience not to mention he's one of
the top you know five ten players in the
world right now so
putting those you know hand in hand he's
a great chess player on the board he's
incredibly fast with his mouse
it's a recipe for success and he's been
doing it for so long right i mean the
guy did it's like a steady diet since he
was a kid it pays to be a beast who just
drops fantastic moves all the time and
be fast it's almost not fair and you
know it's a shame he's not playing here
you know it wouldn't be bullet chess but
he plays fantastic moves and to see his
exciting style here would be great oh
yes
it's a thrill to watch the way he plays
he's so aggressive he's not playing this
minimalist chess stuff he's like going
for the throat yeah and that's produced
some really scintillating victories so
uh yeah we do absolutely miss his
presence here the championship and with
him here this could have truly been the
strongest championship ever yeah i mean
his reign these days is upwards of 27.75
i mean of course that makes the average
rating a lot higher and you know he's
just a fantastic player and if you know
if i can't see him playing the us
championship and do commentary on that
might as well watch him on chess.com
indeed i'll get my hikara nakamura fix
and watch this great chess yeah we we
all like that that nakamura fakes him
being such a fantastic player grand
master robert hess thank you very much
for joining us thank you maurice
back to you guys
well thank you and i was looking for
something like you know a magic bullet
out there he's just like be faster and
be better at chess that's what and play
good moves play good moves and be fast
exactly that's how you're good at blitz
well hikaru wrote people do have opening
he he wrote a book
i do think there's probably some
openings that work better for bullet and
that's kind of what i was wondering
right you can actually download a
database right and just take a look at
that later yeah and just be a systems
player just play same systems
continually be really familiar with
patterns the types of uh that the types
of tactics that occur as well as the
types of endings
like if you're a french defense player
you're familiar with french defense
endings or sicilian player and so forth
and so on well that's the thing that i
think a lot of people erroneously might
think that the more aggressive like e4
players are always going to be better at
blitz and bullet but sometimes the
opposite is true because if you play the
french and the queen pawn openings you
can just kind of like toss out a lot of
moves as you mentioned a system system
opening rather than have to have an open
position where you don't know what's
going on with your pieces one of the
most extraordinary and i really mean
this i i watched him was tigran
petrossian former world champion
but he was a really he was
known as a defensive player and but he's
so familiar with the types of positions
he was a really great blitz player and
only bobby fischer really had the edge
over tigran and tall in the blitz uh
sweepstakes and by the way once again a
shout out to hikaru for being the number
on the first rate the first few day
rating list ever for blitz and bullet of
blitz
and rapid uh hikaru is number one
for sure and by the way just to clarify
uh
robert was saying it wasn't a hundred
and sixty eight games it was closer to
180 i think he was estimating we got the
actual total from chelsea oh we did okay
lovely they that they're i mean 168 and
180 it's pretty close wow
but yeah i um
let me just bring up our crucial game
with the ladies
uh f7 f5
we'll go back just a few moves so i can
just shoot speaking of odds you know i
did an interview with chess.com before
the tournament about what the chances of
irena winning the whole championship
were and what goddess were i said i
would definitely take the field of
regatta well irina i wasn't so sure i
thought it was pretty close
because you know she's the only
grandmaster
she seems to be informed playing a lot
and then really two players that have
really big chances to become champion
besides her right so i thought like 50
with her i really would have been close
but if i had to pick one side it would
be very close spoken like a true las
vegas exactly
obviously she's a point behind even if
she wins this game uh you uh you still
uh you still see ana as a very strong
blitz player with good nerves
um as we saw in the uh the famous or
infamous 08 playoff which i think we'll
play again at some point i still think
that that was one of the greatest most
dramatic uh
um
clips of an armageddon game that you're
ever likely to see very dramatic but
also a little bit i mean you could look
at it both ways because it was extremely
dramatic but it was also like a little
weird because
you know when you have that fast blitz
designing a national championship
and the sometimes the rules and the
movements aren't entirely clear like you
don't really want an arbiter to decide
about like whether the piece is on the
right
square because then it actually becomes
a mess yes you know that you're
interrupting the game adding time to
somebody's thought
just kind of weird like acts of god
instead of chess okay but sport is sport
and sometimes you watch an nba
championship game and the refs aren't
calling fouls or they call a foul on a
tiny touch and the guys are bumping
bumping bumping and no foul gets called
i i mean i just see that as you know
sport and
look uh it was the rules of the time
we don't have those rules anymore now
we're still gonna have really fast chess
if it goes down to the wire but there's
always going to be
some incremental
extra time it's much shorter but right
but i i saw that at that clip and i was
mesmerized by it and
harina's reaction at the end i mean it's
classic i mean that's just that's just
classic if you if you if you don't get
that that's what actually makes the clip
right you see they're moving so quickly
uh by the end of the game but it didn't
have to be that way of course in the
beginning it was a lot of play and then
it goes on and then the very end that
that whacking of that rook well look at
the attention i mean arena you know is
like like thinking uh
you know every move you know what was
the price funded in this it was like 20
000 to the winner or something no no
this was not the saint louis it was not
it was more for the title than the money
i think the money was only at like five
thousand or eight maybe eight thousand
pounds and a lot less than and today and
the title but the titles obviously but
look how fast they're moving you know
just seconds and
the pieces are just fine and anna at the
end
i mean it's the knight flies off the
board doesn't this piece that rook i saw
you fell off the board for no reason
and look at that
ugly controversy afterwards
i know i know what's wrong with ugly
controversy open letters politics
let's play again it's more just like um
like like desire to revoke it it wasn't
really it wasn't really more it didn't
make it more exciting the controversy
that resulted afterwards i think it was
just a little bit like ugly
okay i'm gonna say i'll disagree but
okay what can i say i don't think i
don't think controversy is a bad thing
um
of course you don't want any bad ill
feelings and all that but if you just
took a look at the shot of the two of
them just now
and compare that to what they were just
doing it's clear that the average
audience the lay audience would say wow
the other stuff looked like a lot more
fun right
of course we want to see good chess we
want to see good moves
we want to see the best chess put forth
but if you can't decide it in one time
control and you try a second time
control and a third time control at some
point it's going to come down to this
right it's going to come down to what
may even be a random game but you can't
be there all day you can't play like
game 25 and
withdraw draw george or draw forever so
i i don't i don't mind controversy in
chess i think it's a good thing uh to
have
really dramatic i don't mind controversy
either i just think that the the
playoffs that we had since have also
been extremely exciting and you know
anna blundered in one of those playoffs
as well and there was also a really
thrilling playoff with anna zatonski and
tatev brakamian that went down to the
exact wire as well exactly so i mean it
was it was uh you can go back and look
at some of those matches and that one
was great really exciting that playoffs
and that format by the way was great too
i really like that format instead of the
uh the format we have now which which is
obviously the classic one but the format
where you play
a playoff or play a qualifying stage and
then go down to the final four
that was thrilling i mean what which
year was that jenna it was two years ago
three years that was 2010 i think 2010.
that was exciting we got we had irina
playing
and getting knocked out and then tatev
and and
anna playing at the end and also
exciting one where
our top player hikaru nakamura he was
also knocked out in that playoff and
showed by shulman no that was the year
before i was i wasn't ever it was a
different play
so anyway the one that they were
together the the the one where it was
the knockout that one i think was really
exciting i think that most fans like
that will you qualify into the next
stage and then have a knockout stage
where it's all or nothing none of the
games can go with that well what if we
draw what if we tie you know that's like
nobody's interested in no nobody's as
interested in that i should say even
here i love the fact that a tie results
in a playoffs i mean that's what it
should be i i think there's a good
chance we're going to get a playoff on
one of the championships and um it's
true that sometimes round robin can be
anticlimactic but luckily for us the
fields are tight enough at the top this
year that we don't have any issues right
we've had previous years where agata has
been running away with it or irene has
been running away with it but this year
we're really in luck because ocubian i
guess you could say he's running away
with it but at the same time
he's in trouble against shanklin he's in
a worse position and he still has a
head-to-head battle with kamsky so
exactly just uh all you can really hope
for with this format that we've got so
much excitement it's almost like it is a
round robin but it's playing more like a
knockout in a way
coming down to these decisive games and
i again i'm keeping a very close
watchful eye on the game between anna
and uh arena
we have seen by the way this uh it was a
in this position it was an attempt by um
anna to win the square d5 for her night
you you heard robert hess mentioning
that in case why trades pawns the knight
would eventually come to d5 and if white
didn't trade pawns then after takes the
knight comes to d5 well after thinking
for quite some time
arena came up with f2 f3 so that after
the trade she keeps a watchful eye over
that knight on b6 he controls the d5
square with her e4 pawn no knight moves
i like that even though it's very simple
some concessions right
yes absolutely anna
as black needs to develop counter play
before white simply completes her
development and starts tying black very
seriously to this weakness on c6 i like
arena's choice very much i like her
position i thought that she was in the
driver's seat for some time and she
still is
maurice you got some thoughts to share
as well
yes we have a game that may be over in
the next 10 minutes uh
it may drag on but it's over right now
the position is co-cut busted that
position we showed you i mean this has
to be one of sabino foyza's worst games
where she allowed an incursion onto her
d4 square and then around her king and
take a look at this dramatic development
13 moves in black played knight to e6 as
we suspected and attacked this pawn she
decided to save the pawn a good thing
right now believe it or not was to just
ditch the pawn forget it you don't need
it maybe you're worse but look what's
going to happen to you you're going to
be much worse after knight d4 she played
the move queen b1
look at this cluster of white pieces
completely away from the king all of
them on the queen side the great
alexander alakhine used to do this to
his opponents somehow psyche you out and
get you off on one side and then just
blast your king while victoria knee is
playing in that style because she
recognized that she needed to go all out
for the king she played knight to h5 now
this knight is coming to the f4 square
you don't dare move anything any pawn
around your king because the sacrifice
is going to happen right here she played
the move bishop to b2
that's just too little too late too slow
for what's happening now because the
knight just dropped in on that f4 and
it's just menacing minor pieces
dominating the position the move f3 was
played attacking the bishop that didn't
help because of the simple bishop to h3
nothing to calculate here it's so easy
if you capture the bishop
well you're going to get mated game's
going to be over whichever way you want
to go that's mate oh oops there by the
way there's a rook there too even if
there wasn't it would have been
disastrous so bishop h3
all these guys over here there's nothing
to defend the g2 pawn and a queen is
showing up on g5
houdini's giving g3 saying oh it's
horrible just give the rook up
but you're going to die
this position is virtually resignable a
miniature in
18 19 moves
really bad showing for the player with
the ypg has in fact played g3 and there
goes victoria knee who could have upset
some of the apple card in the
competition she allowed a draw yesterday
against tatev abrahamian when she was
much better we haven't seen her down
here in the interviews at all it's
likely that we'll see her today back to
you guys
yeah i spoke with victoria after her
game yesterday she's just really having
a crisis of confidence she was two pawns
up she acquiesced to a draw in a
position that
virtually everybody would have played
and she herself said if i was feeling
more confident i would play on
today she's being gifted just a simply
scintillating attack on the king side uh
sabina foyser with this move bishop a3
uh clo showed that she didn't have a
full understanding of this middle game
and she is in trouble i noticed in our
our
he did that in inaudible moves whereas
we were pretty easy on victoria i think
we were busy with other games though
well it was round one it was the start
of the championship he was number one
versus number two seeds and there was a
it was a powder puff fight it was a
pillow fight it wasn't it wasn't a sword
fight i noticed on board
it's better to if you're going to take a
draw in a better position you think it's
less shameful if it's later in the game
i think it's important for kids at home
though to see their role models never do
that because kids always try to make
excuses to take a draw exactly because
they want to release attention they want
to relax they want to hang out right
it's like even if you tell them never
ever ever do it they still sometimes do
it so if you start giving examples where
they can yeah then it's all over right
just then they'll just like try to
expand that example and like
that's why so many coaches just have
like a no tolerance policy basically
yeah they learn from what their heroes
are doing and that's why you know again
magnus carlsen hikaru nakamura why i i
have such great admiration for them
because they're trying and they're
exhausting the position of its
possibilities when those guys agree to a
draw everybody in the audience says yeah
i understand why i mean he tried
everything and couldn't make it happen
anna zatonski's an amazing role model
for that too yeah
and they're both those players they play
hard they do whatever they can exactly
and they deserve our applaud and our
admiration and our criticism when they
don't live up to
their levels of professionalism that
they're setting for themselves and again
it's very important to point out to our
professional grand masters that there
are tens of thousands if not millions of
kids that look up to them and will
emulate their play if they show that
they come every day prepared for a fight
well there you go thousands to millions
well
i i i was thinking from the united
states and then i started thinking
globally so i usually think u.s first
and then globally that reminded me of
medesa yesterday talking about how uh dr
dre and signing a billion dollar deal
and like yeah beats yeah yeah if you
don't uh you know think about that in
advance and how to use that money you
might lose it all and i'm like well it's
probably going to be hard for him to
listen
yeah yeah yeah it's a challenge i'll try
300 million dollars
back back in the day that you know
that's uh with inflation that money is
going up but just to comment on the draw
i have an absolute no tolerance rule for
draws with my students i tell them
straight up
no draw offers no acceptances of draws
don't even think about it that's worse
than losing coming back into the room if
you you came back and say oh yeah i took
a draw
what the whole all of the teammates will
will be up in arms we just don't do that
because
it's a horrible horrible habit to get
into you start thinking you know
i don't feel so good i'm a little bit
scared should i play the position once
you get it out of your mind you just
play chess
and that's what it should be should just
be playing chess and
the money that a person might play we
want to see chess go big time so imagine
a spectator comes in to watch our sport
and we ask them to pay to watch
and grey of komski's drawing 14 moves i
mean they're never coming back that's
never they're never coming back it's
just not cool it's just not smart
actually it's not smart from a business
standpoint for chess if it ever wants to
make any strides any inroads into the
american public particularly the
american public where droids really like
kissing your sister
okay interesting comparison there
by the way i would like to point out a
game just very quickly uh between
uh ramirez and onus chuck and robert has
made this point about
honest chuck being down a pawn but
having great compensation but ownership
played a very strange sequence here
after the move rook ac8 king to g2 you
know i'm somebody who loves to sack
pawns for the initiative but after this
move he decided he has to play the move
queen d5
and trade off queens
and
i mean whatever the compensation looks
like in the end game
i can't imagine it's any better than in
the middle game with a move like rook to
e8
i mean rook edit would have really
challenged
white here i mean what could white do we
saw what happened when a queen left or
pieces left to go to the queen side as
in the game between foyzer and knee but
if he hangs out on the king side
then a move like rook c2
and
i mean there's beautiful seventh rank
action there's no way to save this
b-pawn or you're not going to leave with
the e-pawn alone how is this not good
for black i'm really surprised that
ownership decided instead to play queen
to d5 check and go into this particular
end game i mean i'm not saying that this
position is
is bad for him or anything but
i don't know i would i don't think i
would have played this way what about
you guys
i agree i would i would have kept the
queens on the board and played the rook
c2 alex
may be feeling a little bit
less confident in himself
after the turnaround he experienced
yesterday he lost to lenderman with the
white pieces
so
maybe just a little bit unsettled and he
felt that
uh
queen d5 was a safety kind of move we've
got a couple great um comments coming in
from our listeners andrew latham at our
hashtag u.s chess champs says that when
i was in high school i asked hess for
advice about the nationals he surprised
me with a very long detailed and
friendly reply i've been a huge fan ever
since that's a really cool story thanks
for sharing and uh yeah good karma for
robert yeah respond to your fans be kind
and uh he also pointed out that uh don't
forget zatonski blundering her rook in a
one position in the final showdown
versus crash in 2012 even though that
wasn't a sudden death blitz game there
still was a blunder to decide the
championship right and uh we also have
some very exciting news that tomorrow we
are gonna have a very special guest
calling into the show gary caspar
is going to be on the show tomorrow so
you definitely will want to be tuning in
it's going to be at approximately 2 30
central standard time that'll be 3 30
for those of you on the east coast so
okay don't make any big sunday plans
you're going to want to watch us
all day
and with that we're going to go to a
little commercial break
i'm feeling great to be back here in st
louis the u.s championship is my
favorite event by far you play
consistently strong opposition there's
no free games it's always a challenge
right from day one this is my first
year's championship
it is my first visit to saint louis as
well and so far i like it everyone is a
grand master here and everyone's most
people who are playing here have beaten
me before so it's going to be a very
tough turn my approach to chess as
cliche as it sounds is just to play as
many good games as possible i've tried
setting goals before and it all it does
is pretty much sort of constrict my play
it's gonna be probably one of the last
chances for me to win
so uh
i guess my goal is to win coming into
this tournament you're always thinking
games preparation openings middle game
tactics you want everything to be solid
but i'm still trying to be realistic and
just get it one game at a time my
emphasis in the game
is to
learn and improve it's interesting to
challenge yourself and play stronger
opponents and that's definitely
something you find in the yes
championship
i think it's maybe just the feeling of
being back in st louis again it's just a
really really pleasant feeling the
weather is great it's so you can really
feel that it's summer here it's not like
that in new york well uh this year
i'm really trying to win the tournament
i've come close many times i think
my this might be the year i actually win
the tournament each year i compete in
the championships it's becoming harder
and harder to prepare i just finished
with my law school exams two days before
arriving for the championship of course
i will try to win but i i have to be
realistic i didn't play like nfc
astronomers since last year's
championship i had a break from chess so
i will do my best i do what i can think
is that this is just one game i play
with them so
so it doesn't matter they might be
better objectively it's how how we play
the one single game so i want to put all
my efforts to do just the best i can i
really like it because it's really fun
playing against new people and i get to
make new friends
like goal this year is to play fighting
chess and not have a single regret with
any game that i play my dad said um he
said play well
so that's what i'm going to try to do
not just to get lucky but to try to make
some good moves
welcome back to the 2014 us chess
championship and u.s women's chess
championship here in this crucial round
where we see irina crush nursing a small
advantage against anna zatonski small
but
also
seriously everlasting
never
either loses or
manages to simplify matters enough to
get a job
and here's a graphic kind of showing us
how this rivalry has gone over the war
over the years
so in 2013
irena crush won their game in 2012 they
drew but then irena ended up winning the
playoff right right and uh 2011 crush
also won 2010 was a draw in 09 zatonski
um won the game
and uh that was a beautiful game with
the uh the queen sack the queen trap
rather
and also a couple of draws in 08 and 007
and a win for zatotsuki back in 04 which
was probably one of her very first u.s
women's championship i think it was her
first
well those two ladies have basically
dominated women's chess for a decade
here in the united states and been
trading titles between themselves anna
goes into this round obviously a point
in the lead arena in a must-win
situation but arena applying the
pressure
in the game that maurice was talking
about between alejandro ramirez and
onishok
marie's properly questioned what
oni shook was